this is the biggest mistake I see people
make when starting a new diet I'm a
registered dietitian and I see so many
people plan to start a new diet on
Monday or on January 1st after New
Year's and they spend the entire weekend
beforehand binge eating all of the
Forbidden foods that they have left in
the house you know to get them out of
the house before diet starts tomorrow we
call this the last supper effect and
it's such a common Pitfall in dieting
circles that often keeps folks trapped
in a vicious binge restrict cycle they
were strict too hard they binge they say
it I might as well eat all the
things now and start my diet again on
Monday rinse and repeat if you're
falling into this habit it's good
evidence that you're probably
restricting too hard try to allow
yourself some of these forbidden Foods
throughout the week so you don't feel
the need to cram everything in before
they're completely off the table let me
know in the comments below if you've
ever experienced the Last Supper effect
and how you overcame it